welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Deadpool 3 is the MCU crossover
event the studio feels most confident in
the only major release to actually be
moved up as opposed to move back now
releasing May 3rd 2024 and currently
rushing to finish principal production
the more we learn about this movie it
increasingly sounds like Marvel is
positioning it to be the crossover event
we've been waiting for not just one that
shows us some glowing timelines that
says uh oh but actually walks and talks
us through what is happening and finally
finally Bridges the gap between the MCU
and the X-Men so will Deadpool Kill the
fox X-Men Universe because I think
that's what's Happening Here by the way
new rockstars is now a network with
three channels this main channel for
Easter eggs and answers to your burning
questions the Deep dive for special film
analyzes for me and our new channel the
break room for our instant reactions and
our secret Invasion after show subscribe
to all three and support our network
with some merch at nerdrive.shop okay
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman announced
last September that Deadpool 3 was
happening and that Hugh Jackman was
returning as Wolverine offering few
details beyond that but I did make a
video that then decoded what exactly
they were saying via lip reading since
then Ryan Reynolds has done some
flirting on Twitter with the fan account
from his minutes from the TBA and Loki
and it has been confirmed that most of
the cast in the 2016 Deadpool in the
2018 Deadpool 2 are returning including
Marina Baccarin as Vanessa Karen Sonia's
Defender Leslie uggums is blind Al
Brianna hittlebrand as negasonic teenage
Warhead Shirley kutsuna as Yukio Stefan
capichick is the voice of Colossus and
Rob Delaney as Peter from The X-Force we
also learned that Emma Corin who played
Diana Spencer in season 4 of the crown
has been cast as an undisclosed villain
and Matthew mcfadian as Tom from
succession has also been cast rumor has
it as a TVA agent as this movie is
transitioned from development to
production this spring and summer rumors
have swirled around other big names on
February 9th Patrick Stewart told
comicbook.com I've been told to stand by
I know nothing more than that honest on
April 18th Ryan Reynolds told variety
that to get Hugh Jackman to agree to
come back as Wolverine quote what we
pitched him was enough of a Divergence
from the character that he knows and the
character that he's left behind that it
gives them something completely new to
play and something that he's really
excited to do on May 24th a few weeks
into Deadpool 3's production Halle Berry
posted an interesting Instagram photo of
herself with short white hair which many
believe was a sign that she was shooting
scenes as storm for this movie and as
often occurs with these dry news Cycles
online scoopers began to post
unconfirmed Anonymous unsubstantiated
claims that not only Halle Berry but
James Marston Cyclops and Famke Jansen
Gene gray were returning as well the
latest comes from scooper Casey Walsh
who claims that Ben Affleck has been
spotted on set for Deadpool 3 leading
some to speculate that he could return
as Matt Murdoch Daredevil from the 2003
Fox movie now these latest online claims
have not been corroborated by any
legitimate news source so please take
them with a grain of salt again this
often happens with high profile Marvel
releases and half of the claims end up
being bogus and scoopers will often then
shift to things like well I saw concept
art when that concept art was just one
of 12 different things artists pitched
for a movie or there was a conspiracy
where they shot some of the movie but it
was cut there have also been some
rumored leaks coming from places like
Reddit and 4chan which honestly read
like not that bad fan fiction claiming
that the X-Men in this movie will come
from a rogue timeline that Deadpool has
to destroy a universe in which Magneto
won during the events of the 2000 X-Men
movie and created a world dominated by
mutants kind of like House of M but
based on what we know from Ryan Reynolds
has actually said the Wolverine in this
movie must come from a different
timeline than any of the ones Hugh
Jackman has played before in X-Men Days
of Future pastor and Logan and a House
of M Wolverine would be one Logan that
we haven't seen yet on screen while
House of M is best known as a Scarlet
Witch story Wolverine is really the
point of view character the only Marvel
hero who remembers initially that
reality has been altered by the Scarlet
Witch and the one who has to lead the
charge to awaken the others one by one a
wolverine who also comes from reality
where mutants are running the show would
also be a change of pace for the
character rather than being a second
class citizen he'd be a first-class
Citizen and this would allow him to suit
up in a blue and yellow suit and join a
true X-Men task force as we see in the
X-Men animated series and with all also
making more of a fascist villain with a
logical antagonism for a Deadpool trying
to destroy this Authority your enjoyment
of Marvel's secret Invasion will not be
complete if you don't watch inside
Marvel on new Rockstar's new channel the
break room we are going to be answering
all the burning questions after each
episode and stop at nothing to cover all
of the Scrolls in the MCU the break room
is our brand new Channel with breaking
news reactions after shows and some
really fun content that you've never
seen from us before on the break room
you'll see all the new Rockstar's faces
you've come to love as well as friends
of the channel new and old and celebrity
guests will be legally obligated to make
appearances there are some up there
already for real go look for yourself
join us for every episode of secret
Invasion as we pour over all the
evidence to figure out who and who isn't
a scroll in your hottest burning
questions coming out of every episode if
you don't want to miss a single clue
subscribe over at youtube.com breakroom
in R now Ryan Reynolds and Sean Levy and
Hugh Jackman's announcement video imply
that Deadpool and Wolverine would be
fighting in this movie so this would
change the plot to be more of a conflict
a lot Deadpool versus cable than a team
up all the way through if Ben Affleck
Daredevil shows up in this that would
pay off a deleted joke with Charlie Cox
and John Favreau when they shot scenes
and Spider-Man no way home because there
was going to be a reference to the fact
that Favreau played foggy Nelson in the
Ben Affleck Daredevil movie they're
gonna have a line to the effect of my
memory's kind of foggy in addition to
being associate producer for the fox
X-Men film in 2000 feige went on to
produce the 2003 Fox Studio Daredevil
with Ben Affleck and that's where feige
met John Favreau beginning their
collaboration that would lead to Iron
Man in 2008 in the dawn of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I think it's not
too crazy to at least expect this movie
to be a send-off to Kevin feige's pre
MCU history as a Marvel producer
Deadpool kills the fox Universe through
the framework of the TVA Time Bandit
Wade Wilson who used the restricted
device of Cable's time travel watch to
change the timelines in the epilogue of
Deadpool 2 would now have to prune the
most Tangled and nonsensical branches of
the Multiverse and he's the only guy for
that job Deadpool would have to fight
Wolverine and storm Cyclops Jean Gray
Professor X Affleck Daredevil and if the
fox Marvel titles are all on the table
here that would also include the 2005
and 2007 eras of the Fantastic Four
which means Chris Evans as Johnny Storm
Chris Evans is obviously down to Cameo
and Sean Levy Ryan Reynolds movies after
his cameo in free guy so long as Kevin
feige gives his Blessing which you have
to imagine he would this is a lot easier
to pull off than Hugh Jackman returning
his Wolverine to begin with and if this
movie does revisit the climax to the
2000 an X-Men film with Magneto on the
Statue of Liberty here's a perfect
opportunity here to connect that with
the climax of Spider-Man no way home
which opened Rifts in the sky to other
corners of the spider-verse also around
a Statue of Liberty when the Statue of
Liberty First showed up in the trailer
for no way home my conspiracy brain led
me to think this would be the perfect
place to connect these dots and when it
didn't happen I thought well someday and
now all it would take is for Deadpool to
look into a glowing light in the sky
from Liberty Island and to see on the
other side of that Rift Doctor Strange
trying to hold it all together asking
who the hell are you I just think that
if Marvel decided to move up this film
to the Covenant May 3rd 2024 slot Kevin
feige must think he's got a huge hit on
his hands the movie we all wanted Doctor
Strange is the Multiverse of Madness to
be and even better a movie that can make
fun of how that and other Marvel titles
disappointed some people now we don't
know if Marvel will stick with Deadpool
3 as a title so I want to know from you
what title do you think they should go
with Deadpool kills the X-Men Deadpool
versus the Multiverse Deadpool
homecoming yeah I mean that's his sense
of humor not mine but I want to hear
from you comment down below and support
us with a shirt like our secret evasion
inspired shirts at nerdright.shop you
can follow me on Instagram Twitter eavos
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign